and by the way when these people blame  the unvaccinated they're still locking  down in countries where they are almost  entirely vaccinated why do you need any  rules in quebec if it's 80 vaccinated  right you're well past any threshold  that was supposed to be met for hurt  immunity this is are you starting to  understand this has nothing  to do with science and everything to do  with control does it have to get to 90  does it have to get to 99 before you  start rounding up the unvaxed and  blaming them for the biggest spike in  the history of this pandemic at what  point do you say huh maybe it's not the  unvaccinated maybe we have the biggest  spike ever if you were just playing a  percentages game because of the 80  percent who are vaccinated and it still  doesn't give you the right to strip  people of their rights it still doesn't  give you the right to kick some poor kid  with leukemia  out of the ronald mcdonald house  this is where we are in canada